comment tu as été approché pour devenir
la nouvelle
j'étais approché par Alexa la
roche-joubert avec qui je suis pas dans
les Landes
avec qui j'ai toujours été en contact
depuis l'âge de nous alors tu vois nous
Alexis et moi tu en as on se fout sur la
gueule on se souvient et tout on s'adore
c'est vrai mais c'est comme ça c'est
rien
moi tu vois enfin moi j'ai beaucoup de
souvent comme ça avec les gens mais
j'aime bien c'est vrai c'est une femme
une grande femme je te vois pour la
suite oui alors faut savoir que j'ai
toujours un peu resté dans le Gironde
des Miss France j'étais lu mais déjà
Miss France 2005 j'ai tenu des comités
de Miss Normandie Miss Bretagne et puis
et puis tout au long de mes années j'ai
voulu étoffer un petit peu mon CV donc
avec une solide expérience
événementielle et je travaille aussi
entre autres pour la holdine du coup
benijay avec qui elle fait voilà de
beaux projets tout au long de l'année
c'était le 4 décembre 2004 Miss France
2005 Diane vous étiez né
oui oui
j'avais même voté pour elle à l'époque
voilà
mettez-moi Miss France c'est Miss
Normandie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci beaucoup la chorale
ce soir je sais
Cindy j'ai bien vérité je sais ce que tu
ressens aussi quand je revois mon
élection à chaque fois je te jure j'ai
tout retourner ça fait quelque chose ou
pas oui mais oui c'était à 17 ans et
après tu as galéré tu es un conte
qu'après tu as galéré après tu as connu
des années de galère bien sûr c'est
comme ça qu'on se renforce c'est comme
ça aussi que on revient un peu plus fort
effectivement être Miss France c'est pas
simple alors ça l'était pas à l'époque
ça l'était encore moins à l'époque de
Geneviève de Fontenay sylvie a bien mis
en place justement une reconversion
auprès auprès de toutes ces jeunes
filles mais c'est vrai que c'était pas
simple parce qu'on était aussi un petit
peu vous à nous-mêmes mais au final
voilà on réussit à créer sa propre
expérience t'es heureuse oui bien sûr
alors bonne santé c'est ce qui est le
plus important
il est au bout de sa vie
tu pètes le feu moi je voulais qu'on
voit une séquence très drôle c'est quand
tu avais mis un gros râteau en direct à
Christophe Hondelatte à l'époque le
trésor de France 2 il avait l'air de
bien te kiffer regardez tu lui as mis un
vent sur la tête des chats errants
regarde des présentateurs de 13h qui
épousent des Miss France vous êtes au
courant de ça ça s'est déjà vu une fois
ça a eu lieu bah oui mais alors donc il
faut vous attendre à ce que ça vous
arrive on dit jamais 23 donc
ça se fait on peut s'embrasser
alors voilà merci merci beaucoup Sylvie
favor
je ne suis pas une fille facile
beaucoup de messages de femmes pas très
contente qui m'a dit mais comment avez
pu rembarrer Christophe
en plus juste après juste après
l'émission bien sûr on en a rigolé mais
voilà c'était après
m'avoir dit que effectivement toutes les
miss finissaient avec des présentateurs
télé il était hors de question que je
finisse avec lui
[Rires]
elle est chez elle alors
alors tu es triste ou pas
je sais pas si triste c'est le mot
nostalgique des débuts parce que c'est
passé super vite mais en même temps il
s'est passé tellement de choses j'ai
l'impression d'avoir bien réussi mon
année en tout cas dans mes objectifs à
moi et tes objectifs
et finalement
je pense ça a été une super belle
opportunité je suis à la rencontre
de et puis un moment il faut accepter la
passation de lumière quand j'ai eu la
chance que ma vie soit un peu Cendrillon
et maintenant il tente d'accueillir une
nouvelle Cendrillon vous êtes heureuse
de faire la soirée avec Jean-Pierre
Foucault vous allez refaire c'est vous
qui allez remettre la couronne c'est moi
qui m'a oui oui j'ai hâte de voir en
tout cas
après Miss France c'est comme un
ministre après ça y est c'est fini après
on va dans les stands de fromage à pâte
molle on fait un peu de temps
[Rires]
non mais je pense c'est génial par
contre c'est un rythme de vie où
effectivement il faut être hyperactif
quand on dort ce qu'on dort très peu on
est partout à la fin on fait des
transports parfois on peut faire jusqu'à
transport mais en même temps c'est un
kiffe parce que quand on arrive les gens
ils sont tellement contents de nous voir
on fait des choses je vais faire le
Festival de Cannes le lendemain je vais
être au salon de l'agriculture je vais
faire une élection et couronnée ici dans
la Franche-Comté je fais de tout et
après je suis obligé dans la radio de 6h
à 9h30 avec avec jonteau donc c'est quoi
la radio c'est bien ça se passe bien
vous êtes contents très content bon bah
c'est normal
après on aura les premiers chiffres le
23 septembre d'ailleurs
[Rires]
on a les premiers chiffres je serai à la
radio c'est moi-même qui vais décaler
l'ambiance j'espère donc voilà donc je
pense qu'on fera une réunion juste après
merci alors tu as dit dans Paris Match
que c'était une grosse perte pour Miss
France le départ de Sylvie mais tu es
heureuse quand même que Cindy arrive
bien sûr non parce que je pense que
c'est vice c'est un emblème et
effectivement évidemment que c'est une
perte après je pense qu'il était temps
pour elle aussi de passer à autre chose
et c'est et c'était personnel son choix
de le faire et je pense qu'en fait elle
avait rempli tous ses objectifs et je
pense que pour la société Miss France
c'est bien aussi qui est du renouveau on
a hâte de voir ce que ça va donner avec
les nouvelles règles etc ça c'est tout
hein la vérité un changement moi
personnellement j'adore ces villes mais
je suis fou aussi
un t-shirt du marquer fou de ciment je
voudrais dire j'avais dit à Alexia
calixia voilà truc elle aurait pas dû
enlever Sylvie tout ça et ben Alexia je
sais pas si elle m'entend mais bravo
parce que franchement
j'adore fumée elle a le sens on embrasse
Sylvie quand même bien sûr qu'on
embrasse Sylvie voilà se dit envoie-moi
un cadeau et puis on verra
voilà mais pour l'instant c'est vrai que
là Cindy voilà et la lumière je suis
désolé voilà c'est la constante
je suis désolé non mais c'est pas ça
c'est que j'aime bien c'est tu vois
c'est pas c'est pas un cadeau n'importe
quoi elle m'a pas offert du Caprice des
Dieux tu vois maintenant non voilà
j'aime bien c'est personnaliser c'est
beau à la bosser moi j'aime les gens qui
bossent c'est pour ça que je vous
fréquente très peu c'est vrai c'est vrai
je vous fréquente peu le concombre Miss
France c'est le 17 décembre tout à fait
au château qui m'a dit j'ai l'impression
qu'il est très intéressant et c'est vrai
qu'il y en a qui trouve que le concours
mix France voilà
il se renouvelle pas etc ça cartonne
toujours donc on a vu que Alexia et vous
vous alliez donner un nouveau souffle
aussi une nouvelle règle faut-il des
mises tranches genre pour vous
alors dans le règlement ce mot n'existe
pas d'accord nous nous acceptons tout
simplement les jeunes filles avec un
état civil féminin tout le reste ne nous
regarde pas ça relève de l'intime et on
a rien à voilà on a pas notre mot à dire
sur sur tout un travail psychologique et
physique qui a été opérationnel pour
vous Diane
c'est effectivement
on a une candidate qui est qui est en
genre d'hypocrisie là-dedans parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'il y a jamais eu de
Miss transgen ni régional ni national et
qu'aujourd'hui si on le sait on l'aurait
su et aujourd'hui je sais que le comité
aurait envie de communiquer là-dessus si
vous avez envie d'envoyer une image de
modernité non pas forcément au contraire
on rentre dans
peut-être en fait on rentre dans un cas
tellement intime avant c'était voilà
maintenant on en parle librement et
ouvertement mais avant c'était des
sujets très tabous comme l'homosexualité
donc là tout simplement on passe un CAP
en 2022 ou ce mot effectivement ou un
état est vraiment libéré et on en parle
librement là pour moi ça relève de
l'intime je n'ai pas du récemment dans
les régionales
en fait bien sûr est-ce que est-ce
qu'une Miss voilée peut arriver à un
moment alors tout ce qui est signe
ostentatoire politique et religieux n'a
pas pour l'instant n'a pas lieu il faut
qu'on respecte une éthique d'accord
qu'est-ce que vous dites le concours est
grossophobe
absolument pas en fait il faut savoir
que toutes les mises que l'on observe
les miss régionales que l'on observe sur
le plateau de TF1 elles ont été élus et
de l'élection régionale si vous savez je
vous invite à aller en région beaucoup
de jeunes femmes se présentent à
l'élection parce que c'est une sorte
d'exécutoire elle s'assume complètement
et on a du 34 au 42
les discours qu'on a entendus sur
vaillama
un tout petit peu plus pulpeuse que les
autres on va dire et franchement la
communication de a été faite que
là-dessus et vous avez vu une grosse
Miss France je suis désolé mais en fait
c'est grossophobe en fait on a élu en
fait on a eu une jeune fille tout
simplement qui était pétillante et
justement à travers l'écran elle nous a
mais complètement transparente
toute façon Miss France c'est ça je vous
rappelle la caméra elle est là on voit
pas vraiment le corps donc c'est ça
regardez bien non non je vous jure non
non la caméra vraiment les braquer
là-dessus les votes ont lieu dans 15 on
voit beaucoup plus le visage malgré tout
Miss France la caméra
mais c'est pourquoi
vous avez vu mais moi dans ma promotion
il y a pas que des filles qui se
transmis et pourquoi il y avait du 40 40
par contre le pic d'audience c'est
lorsqu'elle exactement qu'elle prenne le
micro et elle s'exprime ouais mais bon
oui on sert à tout c'est un tout c'est
un tout oui mais là encore sur le papier
le concours il est ouvert à tous mais
est-ce que demain dans le nouveau Miss
France que vous incarnez on pourrait
voir des Miss clairement en surpoids qui
ont 20 kg trop 30 kg trop mais qui sont
très jolie
mais bien sûr et on l'observe en région
on l'observe en région avant tout vous
savez c'est une ce sont des élections
qui fait d'air on supporte la mise de
son village et peu importe la taille
qu'elle fait au final c'est parce que
elle vient notre village et donc on va
la supporter jusqu'à la régionale et
pourquoi il y en a jamais qui arrive
jusqu'en final jusqu'à TF1
les gens de voter pour des gens qui a
des filles qui veulent pas parce
qu'elles ont 5 kg
les gens sont en fait cette année pour
la première fois il y a une candidate
déjà maman qui participera au concours
il s'agit de victoire Oslo 27 ans Miss
Alsace
donc
les mamans ça te dérange pas alors moi
je suis maman jally 3 casquettes trois
missions je suis chef de chef de projet
et Associés chez Emma events je gère et
conseils toute la stratégie de marque de
Miss France également talent club je ne
peux pas dire que on ne peut pas en tant
que maman s'accomplir au-delà d'un
certain âge c'est voilà ce sera une
hérésie par contre effectivement
l'emploi du temps il faut juste
s'adapter adapter son emploi du temps on
le sait le nombre de papas maintenant
qui sont papa au foyer
là donc c'est quand même très compliqué
en fait c'est ce que l'on dit c'est ce
que les en région en fait ils prônent il
faut juste il faut s'organiser après ça
relève de votre choix que les régions
c'est un jury qui vote excuse-moi tu
veux parler tout seul
donc effectivement on amène à
transmettre
alors absolument pas ce sont le public
c'est le public qui vote et parmi le
choix du public effectivement le jury
des libères mais il y a quand même il y
a quand même un choix du public oui bien
sûr mais visible
comment ça se passe comment ça se passe
avec Sylvie ça se passe très bien Sylvie
nous accompagne jusqu'à jusqu'au prime
donc tout va bien c'est pas il y a plus
de tension non non absolument pas s'il y
a de très beaux projet donc Cindy oui
pas Sylvie vous avez dit Cindy
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
tu m'as pris ma place tout ça moi je
vois dans le 6 à 7 avec Casta c'est un
panier
de crabe
était ne pas s'éterniser au concours
Miss France donc voilà il fallait elle
avait ce besoin de quitter la société
pour Cindy très contente la façon de
toute manière pour le flambeau il
fallait une ancienne Miss France je
pense que Cindy sera très bien le faire
elle a l'expérience des années des
années derrière elle voilà là c'est vrai
qu'elle arrive en fonction de ma fin
d'année donc ce sera difficile à juger
sur moi on verra que l'année prochaine
ce sera samedi du départ ce qu'elle va
faire comme changement je regarderai
Miss France à vie en 2020
en fait vous avez toujours vous avez
plusieurs écharpe vous en avez une c'est
la qu'une si vous la perdez complètement
quoi c'est pas vrai moi si j'étais Miss
France
dans la voiture je la laisse dans la
voiture de Raymond
votre écharpe oUI NON NON son chat
ça serait bien que tu mettes un petit
coup et je l'ai fait effectivement c'est
incroyable
en tout cas Cindy on t'attendra dès que
pour avec la nouvelle Miss France et
puis Diane tu viens de voir avant la fin
de ton règne si vous m'invitez toujours
bien sûr vendredi à la radio je serai
avec vous dès 6h avec toute l'équipe je
suis très très content juste ça me fait
chier pour jeudi soir je dois me coucher
tôt mais sinon
[Applaudissements]